tchoo hug it out no no and I really mean
it this time
twice you've made me hug you no all
right hey I mean it
I will propose a toast to appreciating
what you have
however long you might have it
the only way that this is bearable for
me
as if I am certain
my sacrifice my death
or protect the people I love there is a
crisis coming we're facing the
destruction of pretty much everything
everything good luck
nice to show up this is the night that
we have been waiting for this city will
be ours less talking more fighting
Indiana Jones made us look way more fun
history's repeating itself
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have a brand new trailer for a crisis on
Infinite Earths the flash season six
arrow Season eight this time mostly from
Oliver's perspective in an explainer for
how they're plotting out arrow season
eight because there's only 10 episodes
yes they did announce they're doing a
pilot for a spinoff with one of the
crossover episodes I'll address that at
the end of the video after I talk about
this footage because it's a little bit
separate that's happening after all the
big crossover stuff happens we're doing
a giveaway for Joker movie tickets all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your best crisis on Infinite
Earths theory on the video you may have
also noticed that Stephen Amell changed
his Twitter avatar to this it's Oliver
standing with Kingdom comes Superman
that's gonna be Brandon rout during the
crossover and you see Brandon Ralph has
been posting pictures of Kingdom Come
Superman so it sounds like he actually
does have a lot of scenes with a bunch
of different supermen this season you
start with the tag from last season
referencing this year's crossover there
were so many moments during the
Elseworlds
episodes that were teasing crisis on
Infinite Earths they were trying to be
very overt about it like please enjoy
what you have while you have it because
the [ __ ] is gonna hit the fan pretty
fast during crisis on Infinite Earths
you hear Oliver talking to the monitor
the only way I can do this if I know
that everyone else is safe everybody
that I love so like he carries that
picture with him as he's travelling
through his past moments they're
basically sending him through all the
greatest hits from arrows best seasons
in all their best episodes but they're
very vague about how he's experiencing
these because the monitors do have the
ability to travel through time and space
but because this is crisis on Infinite
Earths it's mostly a multiverse story
it's not so much a time travel story so
there's some moments that definitely
make it seem like Oliver is traveling to
the Past because they're meant to
reference season 1 season 2 season 3
moments I'll get to those Easter eggs in
a second but then there are some other
things like it seems like they're almost
teasing Tommy
dark Archer which isn't something that
happened within our own continuity that
would have to be another reality there's
also a bunch of flash forwards to the
future with future team arrow Oliver's
daughter and all those villains in the
new version it looks like the person
that's picking up the mantle of
Deathstroke the text at the beginning of
the trailer to the end starts at the
beginning is a double meaning they're
talking about the future team arrow
because it's the beginning of new team
arrow
but they're also starting at the
beginning of arrow season 1 with Oliver
throwing him back into what seems like
his past you see him in his room in the
queen mansion the end of the trailer is
basically him saying hello to his mother
also probably from the same first
episode Stephen Amell posted this
picture with the Moira queen actress and
it couldn't tell if it was a flashback
but I knew that she would be appearing
this season so I'm assuming that she
shows up pretty quickly in that first
episode you see him in the club from the
pilot episode it's almost the same he
starts to notice that things are where
like he's looking at the champagne
bottle cork like what's going on he has
a much thicker beard obviously he's a
couple years older than when he filmed
the pilot so he's meant to look a little
bit different but you also look at Tommy
across the dance room floor who's
staring daggers at him it seems it also
has a beard which he did not have in the
pilot episode which is why I'm talking
about Tommy dark Archer something
different with the Tommy character
something about all these moments that
he's going back to doesn't seem quite
right like he's not literally just
time-traveling and showing up in the
past when you see the camera zoom in on
his eyes and he wakes up in the bed
that's him in Hong Kong so they're gonna
be referencing a lot of season 3 stuff
right away at the beginning of the
season then you see him in a forest that
seems like it's him back on Lian Yu you
see him back in his room during season
one you can kind of chart where he is in
the timeline based on the clothes that
he's wearing in the backgrounds there's
a couple clips of him on a mission in a
warehouse you see him find all these
dead bodies here he does have a new
Green Arrow costume this season this is
what it looks like it's meant to look
very much like an upgraded version of
the season 1 costume a little more lo
Phi but they brought the mask back
Stephen Amell is like everybody knows
his identity so he doesn't need the mask
but the mask just looks way more iconic
so we went with it
the Deathstroke mask that you see
someone pick up then that's in the
flash-forwards all the Deathstroke stuff
the people with the Deathstroke mask
from season 2 they're doing that in the
future timeline so like I said they're
referencing moments from arrows Greatest
Hits episodes but some of that stuff
will be them doing it in the future this
woman with the scar is from the League
of Assassins all that stuff seems like
it's part of Thea storyline because
Willa Holland is coming back for Season
8 episodes in pretty much all the
footage of her in this is her in Nanda
Parbat either a Turin training or it has
something to do with her getting out of
the Lazarus Pit remember she also went
around the
world when she left the show
quote-unquote to destroy all the Lazarus
pits so some of this could be happening
in present day but part of the reason
for including it is because they're
referencing all the season three racial
ghouls stuff that they did more of
Oliver trying to infiltrate what might
be Queen industries because it looks
like he's using his mother's badge here
to get in this might be from the first
couple of episodes I don't know how many
episodes Susanna Thompson is going to be
in maybe just the first episode maybe
the first couple of episodes
you see Oliver's daughter Mia in her
green arrow costume on a mission with
new team arrow this is Renee's daughter
it seemed like she was inheriting the
mantle of the Black Canary in the future
but it's hard to say because Oliver is
wearing the dress shirt here when he's
in Chains going all crazy I'm guessing
this is meant to reference the season 1
episode after Oliver discovered that
Malcolm Merlyn was the dark Archer
Oliver and Diggle meeting up with Black
Canary this seems like it's happening
closer to present-day because she's got
her new haircut this is what her
haircuts gonna look like for most of the
season then you have Oliver battling it
out inside what looks like Queen
industries with what looks like a new
version of the dark Archer I think this
is going to be Tommy that he's fighting
even though I believe that John
Barrowman is coming back for crisis on
Infinite Earths in some capacity they
remind you that the arrow premiere isn't
happening till the week after flash
season 1 so when all the shows come back
they're not all coming back at the same
time really hard to tell if Thea is
fighting Talia al Ghul or she's just
training with her but then you see
Oliver coming for them so he shows up in
this place at some point probably with
the monitors help just as soon as that
the monitor is responsible for all that
craziness but then they go back to arrow
season 3 in the Hong Kong stuff you see
katana comeback for the first time I
think we haven't seen her since season 3
but then you see Oliver with Talia al
Ghul it looks like she's helping him but
if you're wondering why Nyssa al Ghul
isn't back for all this out it's because
Katrina law is on Hawaii five-o totally
different TV show that shoots in a
completely different part of the world
so she's just not available for a lot of
this stuff rogue shot of Lyla I know a
lot of people are wondering because of
crisis on Infinite Earths because Lyla
is the Harbinger in the comics if
they're gonna have some Harbinger Easter
eggs maybe they'll have some references
to that but I'm not expecting her to get
any crazy cosmic level powers or
anything like that
Diggle and what looks like Hong Kong
Diggle might be travelling with Oliver
to a lot of these locations tube because
in an interview
about arrow season 8 David Ramsey said
the Diggle is at Oliver side at pretty
much every step of the way
so wherever Oliver is traveling to all
these different places Diggle is somehow
there with him - you get the big Moira
queen reveal and then obviously the Tom
Welling Superman tag so if it wasn't
clear Tom Welling Superman is going to
participate in this year's crossover
there was news that Michael Rosenbaum
turned down his opportunity to cameo
this is the message that he posted you
could interpret this any way that you
want but the whole idea is is that he
said that it was too last-minute and he
didn't have an idea what he was going to
be doing they weren't offering him any
money
so he had to turn them down I don't
think he's trying to be quite as snarky
as the message makes it seem because if
you saw this it would seem like he's
trying to throw some shade at them it is
a very Lex Luthor type of message to
leave no script no money no pay no deal
they did confirm that Erica Durance is
coming back as Clark's version of Lois
Lane so Lois and Clark will be coming
back from Smallville for the crossover
maybe a lot of languish o up to maybe a
couple of the other small Bell people
but I think Lois and Clark are really
the big ones if you're not gonna be able
to get Lex which is kind of unfortunate
at least you got Lois but addressing all
the arrow spin-off stuff yes there was
news that they're going forward with the
pretty obvious arrow spin-off that a lot
of people assume that they would at
least try with the Canaries in with
Oliver's daughter and future team arrow
they didn't say whether or not it would
be taking place in the future or they
would be pulling her back into the past
because the whole idea in doing this
spin-off is that she would also probably
crossover with the show's in present day
in future years crossovers so there are
five episodes of crisis on Infinite
Earths official crossover three of them
will be happening in December and then
they'll go on break for a couple weeks
come back in January in the second part
of the crossover will air it'll be the
last episode of arrow and then a legends
of tomorrow episode to bookend
everything they said that last episode
of arrow in January is actually going to
be a backdoor pilot for this arrow
spin-off TV show reactions are all over
the board if you're a big fan of all the
future team arrow stuff that they did on
arrow last season you'll probably like
the crossover or if you like these
actresses but if you didn't care about
the future team arrow stuff you're
probably not going to care about the
arrow spin-off there was a new
spider-man 3 teaser with Jay jonah
Jameson I'll do a video for that tonight
there
some brand-new Black Widow I'll do that
tomorrow there's a whole bunch of stuff
coming up as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all the videos when I post them
everybody click here to learn what's
going on with the Black Adam movie and
click here for my brand new Avengers
infinity Saga trailer and Marvel phase 4
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight